willkommen zur zdf heute live mit einem
aktuellen live stream zu einem thema das
heute morgen viele menschen überrascht
und schockiert hat denn das griechische
flüchtlingslager moria auf der insel
lesbos ist in der nacht opfer eines
feuers geworden es gibt mehrere bilder
aus sozialen netzwerken die zeigen wie
das lager brennt wir gucken uns die mal
zusammen an das feuer ist wohl gegen
mitternacht ausgebrochen an mehreren
stellen im camp gleichzeitig sowie das
berichtet am abend soll es im lager
unruhen gegeben haben weil mehrere
menschen sich weigerten in isolation zu
gehen die wurde eine corona infektion
hatten
ob es einen zusammenhang gibt ist
bislang noch unklar
das leider selber ist ja ziemlich
überfüllt schon seit jahren das ist für
knapp 3000 menschen angelegt aber es
befinden sich zurzeit noch 13.000
menschen dort jetzt alle das lager
verlassen mussten die fliehen mussten
natürlich unter schwierigen bedingungen
denn es gibt nicht wirklich platz um das
lager herum bilder aus der nacht zeigen
dann die die menschen versuchen sich in
sicherheit zu bringen und dann teilweise
auf straßen campieren mussten ausharren
bis jetzt in den morgen
wir sprechen darüber jetzt mit niklas
fischer von der ngo mission lang er ist
vor ort auf lesbos herzlichkeit können
sie mich hören 96 hin gerade nur ihr
unteres gesicht vielleicht wenn sie die
kamera noch ein bisschen weiter weg
halten
sie sind ja selber nicht vor ort herr
fischer aber sie sind hier direkt im
kontakt mit menschen vor ort was können
sie uns dass wir die aktuelle lage am
lager ums lager herum sagen
also ich bin so nimmt jetzt gerade so
zwischen der hauptstadt der insel
mittellinie und dem camp mori also auf
halber strecke
ich habe jetzt heute morgen schon wieder
viel mit freunden telefoniert
es gebe es den geht und ja die lage ist
sehr unübersichtlich
die leute oder die meisten damen
wirklich alles verloren nicht nur ihre
unterkünfte sondern auch ihre papiere
und alle ihre zeugnisse all das was sie
aus denen außer von der von der ersten
schlucht quasi mitgenommen haben ist dem
feuer zum opfer gefallen
was natürlich extrem bitter ist auch
krankenakten ausweispapiere alles
verbrannt
wissen sie denn wo die menschen sich
gerade aufhalten es gab berichte dass
sie auf einer autobahn von polizisten
bewacht werden können sie das bestätigen
also was ich weiß ist dass mehrere
geflüchtete versucht haben in die
umliegenden gebirgs hänge oder
olivenhaine man ihr sagt er sich zu
flüchten einige eben auf der straße
einige wollten oder viele wollten dann
auch richtung mittellinie hauptstadt und
das hat die polizei dann ja abgeriegelt
und die personen nicht durchkommen
lassen und ist für mich gehört habt doch
jetzt einige einige die in einem anderen
naheliegenden camp namens car at t
aufgenommen wurden
herr fischer wir sprechen gleich nochmal
weiter eine bitte an unsere zuschauer
die jetzt gerade im livestream zu gucken
und auch kommentieren können bitte
halten sie sich an die netikette
beleidigende und menschenfeindliche
kommentare müssen wir sofort löschen und
werden auch dann gegen die user vorgehen
der fischer wir reden gleich nochmal
weiter meiner kollegin stefanie heiß und
ganz riesig fischer haben nämlich noch
mal kurz versucht zusammenzufassen was
bislang über das feuer bekannt ist alles
steht in flammen
die menschen in moria sie müssen wieder
fliehen
diesmal aus dem völlig überfüllten
flüchtlingslager bevor das feuer hier
ausbrach machte die nachricht über
mittlerweile 35 corona fälle die runde
unruhen brachen aus wenig später hat es
maria an mehreren stellen angefangen zu
brennen
meine hütte ist weg meine kleidung
einfach alles
den bewohnern bleibt keine andere wahl
sie strömen auf hügel in die wälder
schlafen auf den straßen
es ist eine unübersichtliche lage für
die behörden
zumal das lager gerade erst unter
quarantäne gestellt wurde
die ursache des verheerenden brandes ist
noch unklar
es stehen anschuldigungen im raum dass
bewohner das feuer aus wut gelegt hätten
andere behaupten inselbewohner seien die
brandstifter verletzte gibt es laut
ersten berichten zufolge keine auf
twitter kritisiert der grünen
europaabgeordnete marquardt egal wer das
feuer gelegt hat in moriya verbrennt
auch die europäische idee das feuer ist
nach regierungsangaben mittlerweile
unter kontrolle
griechenlands ministerpräsidenten
mitsotakis berief eine krisensitzung ein
denn es braucht antworten schon vor dem
brand standen die bedingungen in dem
lager in der kritik viel zu viele
menschen auf viel zu wenig raum 12.000
an der zahl und genau die haben jetzt
nicht einmal mehr ein dach über den kopf
[Applaus]
irgendwelchen live zugeschaltet nicht
direkt vor ort sondern ein paar
kilometer von aussage des lagers aber er
hat natürlich gute kontakte ins lager
selber und auch zu bewohnern der fischer
es gab gerüchte dass das gestern abend
eine art aufstand gegeben haben soll und
lager weil sich menschen geweigert haben
sich zu isolieren
corona infektion und dass das im
zusammenhang stehen könnte mit der
brandursache haben sie da irgendwelche
informationen wenn sie zu uns bestätigen
möchte ich abends in auftrag
also ich habe zumindest das was ich
gehört habe ja das ist keine aufstände
ich habe das selber nicht gesehen
deshalb möchte ich die gerne
irgendwelchen spekulationen hingeben
aber was das bestätigen kann ist das
einfach die stimmung über die letzten
wochen die letzten monate dieser
lockdown oder diese gar anja der lok der
existiert da schon seit seit monaten die
leute werden hier zusammengepfercht gibt
tiere und seit dem bekanntwerden des
ersten carola fall ist letzte woche
wurde dieser lockt auch nochmal nochmals
strikt durchgesetzt und die stimmung das
hat man gemerkt wer die letzte woche
hinweg wurde immer aufgeheizter als die
sowieso schon war
und ja aber warum will kann sich auch
die menschen in isolierung zu gehen dass
man das interesse von einem und angetan
zu sagen ich gehe mal zwei wochen
bisschen weiter weg und versucht nicht
noch mehr menschen anzustecken
das kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
beantworten sagen okay die bedingungen
haben sie gerade schon gesagt werden
immer schlimmer das leider ist ja für
knapp 3000 menschen ausgelegt da sollen
sich 13.000 menschen aufhalten können
sie versuchen uns das ganze schildern
unter welchen bedingungen die menschen
dort leben die kann ich mir das
vorstellen als westeuropäischer mensch
und warmen stuben
also ich finde ein ganz guter vergleich
so pervers der auch irgendwie ist der
vergleich ist der vergleich mit einem
rockfestival
man fährt auf dem festival für ein paar
tage manche nicht schlecht es ist heiß
im zelt es ist laut überall sind ja die
die sanitäranlagen sind eine katastrophe
wenn man auf klo möchte muss man 100
meter weit laufen
man muss sich die toiletten mit tausend
anderen teilen
es gibt auch auf sind es gibt auch ja
krawalle
es gibt hier noch keine musik und das
festival ist unbegrenzt also so wo wir
nach hause fahren nach drei tagen fest
ich würde sagen es war schön aber jetzt
auch wieder jetzt reicht's auch wieder
und ich gehe jetzt mal waren duschen
das können die leute eben nicht die sind
auf unbestimmte zeit ja und das frisst
sich in die köpfe und dass das macht was
mit den menschen welche perspektive
sehen sie uns überhaupt gibt es
überkapazitäten irgendwo auf lesbos dass
die menschen jetzt woanders und
kommen können ehrlich gesagt weiß ich es
nicht aber ich weiß nicht einfach nur
eine verlagerung auf auf der insel halte
ich auch für keine wirkliche lösung
sondern es muss jetzt einfach der moment
gekommen sein wo neben deutschland sich
auch andere länder bereit erklären diese
paar wenigen menschen aufzunehmen die
ist hier sind wie ist die stimmung auf
lesbos generell es gab immer wieder
berichtet dass auch die anwohner das
heißt die die menschen vor ort dieses
lager nicht mehr haben wollen also die
stimmung so wie ich sie wahrgenommen
habe ist ja das ist immer subjektiv ist
sehr gemischt es gibt viele leute die
sehr hilfsbereit sind auch über die
letzten jahre hinweg unfassbar tolle
menschen natürlich gibt es auch menschen
die komplett dagegen sind was hier
passiert was ich auch zum teil verstehen
kann wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin also es
kann ja keinen dauerzustand sein was ihr
passiert aber die frage ist wie man das
wie man damit umgeht die man damit
debattiert und dass man dann zu gewalt
greifen die granden angreift in the sun
gleich dieser letzte nacht passiert ist
das kann keine lösung sein das muss
scharf verurteilt werden so der fischer
ich schaue mal ob es eine frage hier an
sie gibt die sie direkt beantworten
können können sie überhaupt in das lager
run ist es möglich dass sie jetzt noch
mal näher rangehen und von da irgendwie
mal schauen wie die lage ist oder sind
sie da werden sie von der polizei
gestoppt
also ich habe es vor mich ans lager
heranzutasten auf legale weise
heute morgen habe ich schon ein versuch
unternommen
da wurde ich auf halber strecke von der
polizei gestoppt durch eben die freunde
geschrieben eine polizeiabsperrung ich
von der einen seite die geflüchteten
daran hindert richtung stadt zukommen
auf der anderen seite auch den verkehr
um leitet das ja auch kein mensch der
andere richtung kommen
ich hab mir mal einen kommentar
vielleicht können sie da was zu sagen
ufa brand schreibt auf facebook
folgendes hier brennt auch in einer
mehrfach gespaltenen gesellschaft so
leid mir die menschen auch tun wir sind
nicht für das elend der ganzen welt
verantwortlich
mit den humanitären hilfen hätten die
länder dieser menschen mal gesundheits
und sozialsysteme errichten sollen sie
haben ja mit vielen der geflüchteten
kontakt was sagen sie dazu
ja ich würde es sind menschen und es
wird immer pauschal gesagt der
geflüchtete der flüchtlinge
hinter jeder in der jeder mensch sieht
genauso hier eine geschichte eine
motivation ein ziel ein traum
und das wird meiner ansicht nach viel zu
oft außer außer sich gelassen also ich
finde jeder sollte sich mal gedanken
machen wie es wäre wenn wenn es
andersrum wäre wenn in deutschland so
etwas aufbrechen würde dann krieg wäre
wenn wir fliegen müssten dann würden wir
auch hoffen dass uns menschen helfen und
das passiert hoffentlich nicht aber
genauso sollten wir halt auch
hilfsbereit sein
haben sie hoffnung dass jetzt diese
katastrophe heute nacht etwas bewirken
könnte tatsächlich in der eu das die
menschen von der insel gelassen werden
und dann woanders unterkommen
nachdem was die letzten monate passiert
und ehrlich sagen es ist die hoffnung da
sehr gering allerdings ja man kann nur
hoffen dass jetzt wirklich etwas
passiert denn das kann kein weiterer
kein zustand noch für weitere längere
zeit sein
herr fischer vielen dank erstmal jetzt
für die ersten eindrücke von der insel
lesbos wenn es wieder was neues werden
wir schauen ob er wieder mit ihnen
sprechen können
bis hierhin erstmal vielen dank so ich
kann noch mal zusammenfassend für alle
die gerade erst dazu kommen was dort auf
der insel lesbos im flüchtlingslager
moria heute nacht passiert ist wir haben
ein paar bilder vorbereitet und zwar ist
das feuer wohl gegen mitternacht
ausgebrochen eine mehreren stellen im
camp gleichzeitig die behörden vermuten
daher brandstiftung wer den brand gelegt
haben könnte ist aber noch völlig unklar
am abend soll es im lager unruhen
gegeben haben weil sich mehrere bewohner
wohl geweigert haben in isolierung zu
gehen aufgrund einer corona infektion
der grund dafür ich habe gerade mit
herrn fischer darüber gesprochen dass
auch noch unklar warum sie das nicht
wollten
die bilder aus der nacht zeigen halt
wirklich dass das komplette lager in
flammen steht und die behörden in
griechenland haben wollen auch
mitgeteilt dass es wohl völlig zerstört
ist die menschen konnten evakuiert
werden muss man gibt es keine berichte
über verletzte oder tote
aber die menschen sind das natürlich in
der gegend um das lager herum verteilt
man hat die haben wir bilder bekommen
von menschen die auf der straße
kampieren am wegesrand jetzt einfach aus
haben müssen wir sehen uns hier mit
kleinen kindern und es ist völlig unklar
wie das jetzt weitergehen soll darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit unserem brüssel
korrespondenten stefan leifert der die
flüchtlingspolitik der eu schon seit
jahren beobachtet
da ist er hatte stefan gibt es daneben
gibt es schon erste reaktionen aus der
eu aus den verschiedenen ländern auf
diese katastrophe heute macht er solche
reaktionen gibt es die sind sehr
emotional und geprägt von von schock und
bei vielen auch wirklich gut ich glaube
die eu realisiert dass sie hier nicht
nur vor den überbleibseln eines
abgebrannten flüchtlingslagers steht
sondern auch vor den trümmern der
gemeinsamen oder eben nicht gemeinsame
asyl- und migrationspolitik die im
grunde seit fünf jahren immer wieder
versucht worden ist zu lösen und den
knoten zu durchschlagen
das ist aber nicht der fall und ich
glaube dieser fall moorea der zeigt
jetzt nochmal wie dringlich dieses
problem wäre als ganz akute notfallhilfe
hat die eu-kommission auch schon
reagiert und hat versprochen sich zu
kümmern um 400 unbegleitete
flüchtlingskinder dies zuletzt den moria
noch gelebt haben sie will den transport
dieser kinder finanzieren und
organisieren die kinder sollen gebracht
werden aufs griechische festland das ist
das was die eu kommission jetzt heute
morgen als erste reaktion angekündigt
und versprochen hat aber dennoch bleibt
ja eine ziemlich große zweite folge
frage was passiert mit denen immer noch
verbleibenden ja über 10.000 erwachsenen
flüchtlingen die moria gelebt haben und
die jetzt ohne obdach sind und schon bei
dieser frage beginnt der politische
streit auch vor dem brand hat es eine
disco
schon gegeben über die frage ob man
dieses lager in moria nicht möglichst
vor dem winter möglichst auflösen sollte
und die menschen evakuieren sollte aber
schon da beginnt der politische streit
über die frage wohin dann mit diesen
menschen ist jedenfalls hat sich keine
ausreichend große zahl von ländern
bereit erklärt diese flüchtlinge dann
innerhalb der eu zu verteilen und
aufzunehmen bevor wir das nochmal gleich
vielleicht kurz zusammenfassend
erläutern war ja nicht alle mitbekommen
haben was in den letzten monaten in der
eu diskutiert wurde es vielleicht noch
mal ganz kurz akut innenminister
seehofer hat heute sich schon dafür
ausgesprochen jetzt nicht länger
pauschal auszuschließen mehr mehr
menschen aufzunehmen das sei als
nothilfe gefragt ist es überhaupt jetzt
möglich könnte die bundesregierung jetzt
einfach oder auch die eu in anderen
ländern einfach flugzeuge losschicken
die menschen überholen und sagen ihr
bleibt jetzt hier
wenn der politische wille dazu da ist
dann würde das technisch und rechtlich
auf jeden fall gehen wir haben das ja
ein letzten in den letzten monaten immer
wieder auch erlebt bei der frage was tun
mit den immer wieder in sizilien an der
italienischen griechischen küste
anlanden den flüchtlingsbooten die er
immer wieder mit zahlen von 40 50 60
flüchtlingen auf den inseln angekommen
sind keine wirklich großen zahlen aber
dennoch
sie zahlen für politischen streit und
sprengstoff gesorgt haben und immer
wieder hat sich dann eine zahl von
ländern von eine kleine zahl von ländern
bereit gefunden
diese menschen aufzunehmen deutschland
war meistens dabei ebenso die
benelux-staaten und theoretisch könnte
man das mit den über 10.000 menschen die
jetzt in moria ohne obdach sind auch
machen
man müsste nur eine ausreichend große
zahl von ländern finden die bereit sind
dabei mitzumachen
kannst du da vielleicht auch noch mal
kurz die zusammenfassung machen der
letzten monate welches land sperrt sich
wie und wie ist die diskussion
mittlerweile festgefahren und bewegt
sich ja eigentlich keinen millimeter
mehr
das stimmt im grunde teilt sich die eu
oder teilen sich die 27 mitgliedstaaten
da in drei lager es gibt vor allem den
süden dazu griechenland dazu gehört vor
allem auch italien eine fraktion von
südländern die ganz dringend dafür sind
jetzt ganz schnell innerhalb der
europäischen union einen
verteilungsmechanismus einzuführen also
wegzukommen von dem prinzip dass das
land für flüchtlinge zuständig ist wo
diese flüchtlinge zum ersten mal
europäischen boden betreten das ist die
sogenannte dublin verordnung und die ist
gescheitert das kann man glaube ich
bilanzieren aus den letzten fünf jahren
die sich die europäische union jetzt mit
dieser frage beschäftigt diese länder
rufen danach ein solidarität seien
verteilungsmechanismus einzuführen der
dann dafür sorgt dass flüchtlinge die
vor allem in griechenland und in italien
ankommen dann über die eu verteilt
werden
dem gegenüber steht eine ziemlich laute
fraktion von osteuropäischen ländern
wortführer ist der viktor orban die sich
genau gegen diesen verteilungsschlüssel
wehren und sagen das ist nicht unser
problem wir haben mit der verteilung
dieser flüchtlinge nichts zu tun das
sind die zwei verhärteten fronten und
dazwischen gibt es eine fraktion von
ländern und dazu würde ich jetzt auch
mal deutschland zählen vor allem im
moment in der rolle als
ratspräsidentschaft die versuchen zu
vermitteln und sagen wir können die
länder des ostens nicht aus der
verantwortung entlassen aber vielleicht
gibt es formen von solidarität die auch
in anderen dingen bestehen können als
darin nach einem festen schlüssel
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen also man könnte
ja auch zum beispiel sagen
ungarn muss nicht unbedingt nach einer
festen zahl oder nach einem festen
schlüssel flüchtlinge aufnehmen sondern
könnte ja zum beispiel einen
finanziellen beitrag leisten
das wäre eine möglichkeit
so einen beitrag zum grenzschutz zum
beispiel oder geldbeträge zu zahlen
damit andere länder in der lage sind
diese flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
der sicher welchen und gesagt halt sagen
dass die eu jetzt auch in den nächsten
tagen vorschlagen will
gäste die möglichkeit zu sanktionieren
und dann zu sagen auch mal gemacht dass
die möglichkeit zu sanktionieren und zu
sagen wenn ihr nicht mitmacht dann gibt
es halt weniger user subventionen zum
beispiel auch das wäre theoretisch
möglich man müsste das politisch zu
beschließen das ist in der eu bei
solchen fragen immer schwierig weil dazu
einstimmigkeit benötigt würde
aber man könnte einen solchen
mechanismus einführen das wäre am ende
ja nichts anderes als der bruch von
eu-recht und wenn ein land eu richte eu
recht bricht und das gibt es ja immer
wieder mal dann könnte man vor den
europäischen gerichtshof gehen und das
dann einklagen und wenn es dann immer
noch dabei bleibt könnte man auch
sanktionen und strafgelder dafür
einfordern so stefan ich hab ja mal in
die kommentare geguckt wir können auf
meinen rechner schalten
da gibt es einen kommentar auf youtube
von rainer kalb der schreibt die leute
müssen eingeflogen werden die
menschenrechtsverletzungen auf dem
mittelmeer und den europäischen
flüchtlingslagern müssen aufhören
ist das tatsächlich so kann man das als
menschenrechtsverletzungen bezeichnen
stefan leifert in brüssel unser
brüsseler korrespondent und wenn ja
inwiefern macht sich die eu vielleicht
auch schuldig
es ist eine schwierige frage ob man das
so hat die menschenrechtsverletzungen
seitens der eu bezeichnen kann
da wäre ich vorsichtig aber ich glaube
völlig unzweifelhaft ist dass man ja gar
nicht so weit gehen dass man kann ja
auch sagen auf europäischen boden also
in griechenland auf den griechischen
inseln leben menschen zu
menschenunwürdigen bedingungen die eu
trägt dazu bei dass sich daran nichts
ändert und allein das ist für viele
schon appell genug um die europäische
kommission oder auch die 27
mitgliedsstaaten immer wieder daran zu
erinnern dass dieser zustand kein
dauerzustand sein kann und dass es
endlich eine gemeinsame und dann auch
wirklich gemeinsam angewandte
europäische migrationspolitik geben muss
stefan leifert vielen dank bis hierhin
erstmal wir werden das thema die
nächsten monate auf jeden fall immer
wieder auf dem tablett haben
aber hier machen wir erstmal ein punkt
und ich danke dir für deine antworten
ich schaue jetzt noch mal hier bei uns
in die kommentare ob die sachen sind die
top band beantworten kann ich habe hier
eine frage von anke k auf youtube die
möchte wissen wer hat das feuer gelegt
das ist bislang wie gesagt noch unklar
das kann man bis jetzt noch nicht sagen
dass wir auch noch viel zu früh das
dauert immer ein paar tage bis teilweise
auch wochen bis die brand ermittler dann
tatsächlich eine brandursache gefunden
haben und ob das setzt eine ein unfall
war auch dass anwohner oder bewohner des
lagers waren ob das vielleicht leute von
außen waren das kann zur zeit überhaupt
nicht gesagt werden
lara dilara fragt bekommen die
wenigstens was zu essen und was zu
trinken auf diese frage kann ich gerade
nicht wirklich beantworten ich kann es
tatsächlich nur hoffen das sind ja
flüchtlingsorganisationen vor ort nicht
mehr so viele muss man sagen weil die
stimmung auf dem auf der insel immer
schlechter wurde und es auch angriffe
gab es so dass viele ngo s ihre
mitarbeiter abgezogen haben aber es sind
immer noch welche da wir haben ja gerade
mit einem sprecher niklas fischer von
der mission lifeline gesprochen der ein
bisschen was dazu sagen konnte
sie wollte auch wissen lager was mit den
menschen jetzt passiert das können wir
auch noch nicht sagen
die situation ist ja quasi sehr akut
heute nacht entstanden und da müssen wir
jetzt die nächsten tage gucken was mit
den menschen tatsächlich geschieht dann
schaue ich mal ob es noch eine andere
frage gibt die wir so beantworten können
ich hatte gerade auf youtube klopp ich
noch etwas gesehen wenn die kollegen
noch mal rüber schalten würden
julius möchte dessen weiß man wo genau
die flüchtlinge gerade untergebracht
sind wir haben ja gerade bilder gesehen
julius die haben wir auch ein geschleift
dass die menschen erstmal ums lager
herum märz untergebracht sind es gab
meldungen dass mehrere von ihnen auf
einer autobahn kapieren dort auch von
der polizei bewacht werden und niklas
fischer hat uns von der mission live
ihren auch gerade im gespräch bestätigt
dass die menschen quasi nichts weiter in
die dörfer gelassen werden und jetzt
dort ums lager wohl herum ausharren
müssen aber die lage ist sehr
unübersichtlich gerade so
ansonsten sehe ich jetzt gerade
zumindest auf youtube keine kommentare
die ich hier beantworten kann dann würde
ich sagen machen wir den stream für
jetzt erst mal zu das danke euch und
ihnen für die aufmerksamkeit und für die
fragen wenn es etwas neues gibt werden
wir uns auf jeden fall wieder melden
dass dahin sage ich einen schönen tag
noch